[موسيقى]
هلا بكم عبد القادر عياد
وتطور اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم هذه
الصور من كياب التي تعيش على واقعي صدمه
كبيره جرا مصرعي 17 شخصا بينهم وزير
الداخليه
قرب المدينه
الى واشنطن ولقاء بين وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ونظيره التركي مولود شاوش اوغلو
ويبحث الجريبان قضايا مختلفه من هذا ساعي
السويد وفنلندا للانضمام الى النيتو
وفي مواضع الحصاد هذه الليله
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه تقضي بابعاد
الزعيم حزب الشمس من عضويه حكومه نتنياهو
وفد من الكونجرس الامريكي يرفض لقاء اي
ممثلين عن حزبين يمينيين مشاركين في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي وضح في اسرائيل متى ترقبه اداره
من نتنياهو وحكومته والبيت الابيض يقول ان
سوليفان سيؤكد التزام واشنطن بحل الدولتين
يدعو الى الاسراء في تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات ومنظومات الدفاع جوي صوت البرج
يؤكد ان الناتو سيزود كيان باسلحه اثقل
واحدث وفي مقابلات مع الجزيره الرئيس
الايطاني ووزير خارجيه فنلندا ووزيره
خارجيه سلوفينيا يؤكدونا دعم اكياف وبوتين
يتهمونيتو بشان حرب على روسيا انطلاقا من
اوكرانيا ويقول ان انتصار روسيا في الحرب
حتميه
مصرع وزير الداخليه الاوكرانيه في تحطم
مروحيه فوق روضه اطفال بضواحي كياب
السلطات تقول انه كان في طريقه الى احد
خطوط الجبهه في خاركيز عندما تحطمت
المروحيه زي الاسكي يامر بفتح تحقيق في
الاسباب ورئيس الوزراء يعين قائد الشرطه
قائما باعمال وزير الداخليه
محادثاتنا امريكيه تركيه في واشنطن تشمل
توزيع عضويه
التعاون بين البلدين كحلفين في النيتو رغم
وجود بعض الاختلافات وزير الخارجيه
التركيه يقول ان انقراض تتوقع موافقه
واشنطن على بيعها طائرات اف 16
ماشيين مع المصالح الاستراتيجيه المشتركه
ورده على تحفظ التركي وزير خارجيه فنلندا
يقول للجزيره ان بلده نفذت التزاماتها
بموجب الاتفاق مع تركيا
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد قبل منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم تحذير الاتحاد
التونسي للفلاحه والصيد البحري بالنفاذ
المخزون الاستراتيجي من عدد من المواد
الغذائيه الاساسيه قبل اساسيه من دخول شهر
رمضان الذي عاده ترتفع فيه او يرتفع فيه
حجم الاستهلاك واعلن مساعد رئيس الاتحاد
انيس خرباش ان النقص في انتاج الالبان على
سبيل المثال يبلغ
35% هذا ويتهم الرئيس السيد من يصليهم
المحتكرين بالوقوف وراء هذه الازمه
استطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما سبب
تراجع المخزون الاستراتيجي من المواد
الغذائيه الاساسيه في تونس
37% قالوا ان السبب هو السياسات
الاقتصاديه المتابعه وقال 84% ان الازمه
السياسيه هي السبب وراء 15% ان غياب
البرلمان ورقه بابته هو السلام
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروح انا على منصتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصه الرقم يتجدد يوميا تفرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وفي فقره المتابعه نرصد دلالات ارسال
الولايات المتحده ذخيره مخزنه في اسرائيل
الى اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اصدر القضاء الاسرائيلي قراران يلزمك ياهو
باقاله وزير الداخليه والصحه والزعيم حركه
مدانا بتهرب الضريبي من جهه اخرى افادت
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه وامريكيه بان
وفدا من الكونغرس الامريكي يزور اسرائيل
في حكومه نتنياهو
مع زياره مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جاكسون لاسرائيل وهي زياره يقول مسؤول
امريكي انها ستوضح ما تتوقعه واشنطن
متاعب مبكرا هل توقعها بنيامين نتنياهو
حكومه
الجامعه بين التطرف اليمني والتشدد الديني
تواجه ما بدا انها اولى الطلبات
الاسرائيليه العليا الداخليه
بسبب خطه اصلاح قضائي مثيره للجدل
تلك التي خرج الاف اسرائيليين قبل ايام
لابداء معارضتهم لها هؤلاء يخشون ان
التوليفه الحاكمه الجديده تنقلب على
النظام القضائي وانها تسعى لانهاء اسرائيل
كدوله ديمقراطيه وفقا لما يقولون
والحقيقه ان الخشيه من توجهات ذلك لاقتلاف
ليست اسرائيليه صرفه
على عناصر حكوميه اسرائيليه بعينها
خيمه المساله بشكل جلي على زياره وفد من
اعضاء الكونغرس الامريكي يضم ما يعرف
بتجمع اتفاقات ابرهم في مجلس الشيوخ فبحسب
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه وامريكيه طلبت
رئيسه الوفد
عندما اشتراكه ممثلين عن حزبين دينيين
ممثلين في حكومه خلال اجتماعاته في
اسرائيل
يتعلق الامر هنا بحزب العظمه اليهوديه
وحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه اللذين يراسهما كل
من وزير الامن القومي اثمر بنج فير ووزير
الماليه بيتسرائيل
كما يبدو على تاذيم العلاقه مع اداره في
واشنطن ربما تثار المساله بطريقه او باخرى
خلال زياره المرتقبه لمستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جاكسون لاسرائيل تلك زياره توطئ
التي ستقود وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى
اسرائيل والاراضي الفلسطينيه اواخر الشهر
الجاري لكنها وفقا لمسؤول امريكي
[موسيقى]
للبحث في هذا الملف ينضم الينا من واشنطن
جيم موران عضو مجلس النواب الامريكي
السابق عن الحزب الديمقراطي وكذلك من رام
الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمباد الوطنيه الفلسطينيه اهلا بضيفيه
الكريمين وابدا بضيفي من واشنطن السيد
موران فيما يتعلق بالسؤال الجوهري لهذا
الانذال الدبلوماسيه الامريكي في تل ابيب
وما تعلق بسيسو
البرلماني الذي وصل ما الذي تتوقعه واشنطن
وتريده من نتنياهو
يعملونا ان السيد نتنياهو سوف يقول اللهم
بانهم لا يؤيد اراء وزرائه
وخاصه
الشخصيات العنصريه الدينيه
والسيقولون للسيدنا
بان الدعم الذي
اسرائيل
ودعم عسكريا والدبلوماسيه هو النتيجه
اراء الم- الجالي او الجوجل الاغالبيه
الجاهليه اليهوديه في الولايات المتحده
وان رئيسه هذا الوفد سنه روزن كانت
في نيفادا
ونناق السبعه
اعضاء مجلس الشيخ بعضهم من الاسرائيليين
وهمم يهود وبالتالي عندما
يتواصلون
رساله التي لديهم بان هذه الحكومه الجديده
ليست
ليست في الحقيقه تستحق الدعم الامريكي
الذي لطالم حصلت عليه اسرائيل وبالتالي
هذا امرلا لم يكن له مهما ان سيدنا قد
يكون متغطرس جدا ولا يصغي لها هذه الرساله
رغم انها رساله مهمه ومن المهم ان تسليمها
ياتي عن طريق وفد من الحزبين النجموريين
الديمقراطيين ما اثرته في اخر كلامك سيد
يا دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي في ما هي حظوظ ان
ينجح مستشار الامن القومي وكذلك هذا الوفد
من الكونغرس في ان يوصل هذه الرساله
للحكومه الاسرائيليه ويريدون جوابا واضحا
كما تقول اداره الامريكيه
شيء جيد اول عن انه اعضاء الكونجرسون مجلس
الشيوخ رفضوا ان يلتقوا بنج فيروس
الفاسيان لانه يعني يعرفوا انهم يمثلوا
احزاب فاشيه ولكن الموقف الامريكي اضعف
مما يجب اضعف بكثير لانه قائم على افتراض
خاطئ بان نتنياهو يختلف في سياسته عن باقي
اركان حكومته نتنياه شخصيا هو المسؤول عن
التطرف القومي هو شخصيا مسؤول عن تدمير ما
سمي بعمليه السلام هو المسؤول عن تدمير اي
فرصه لقيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله والحكومه
الحاليه تمثل ااه تزاوجا ما بين العنصريه
القوميه التي يمثلها نتنياهو والاصوليه
الدينيه المتطرفه الفاشيه الموجوده في
حكومته وبالتالي انا برايي ايه المواقف
التي تقال من الجانب الامريكي ضعيفه اذا
ارادت الولايات المتحده ان تحدث تغييرا
حقا فعليها ان تهدد بفرض عقوبات وهذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لن ترتدع الا بوسيلتين اولا بمقاومه الشعب
الفلسطيني على الارض وثانيا بفرض عقوبات
ومقاطعه عليها وهذا ما يجب ان يجري على
الصعيدين العربي والدولي طيب سيد نورا في
متعلق بهذه النقطه الاساسيه ذكرها الضيف
الدكتور مصطفى فيما يتعلق كيف لهذا الوفد
الامريكي ان يكون فاعلا حيا لما طلبه من
الجانب الاسرائيلي الان الحديث في اسرائيل
ان ما تقوم به حكومه نتنياهو حتى فيما
يتعلق به المحكمه الاسرائيليه العليا انما
الهدف منه القضاء على فكره الدولتين فيما
تقول واشنطن بانها ما زالت ملتزمه بحل
الدولتين وبالتالي ماذا تملك الاداره
الامريكيه من اساليب حتى لا يتم الوصول
الى هذا الهدف هدف حكومه
ايران
المتحده
تحاولوا ان توضح لاسرائيل
بانه لو ان حل الدولتين رفع عن الطاوله
ويبدو ان هذا حاصل حاليا
في اسرائيل سوف تعاني نتيجه ذلك
ليس على في البدايه لكن على المدى البعيد
لان بقيه العالم لن يعاقب
حكومه لن يقبل واللي يوافق الحكومه ذات
فصلا عنصري
الحادي والعشرين
وهذا هو بالضبط
ولا استطيع ان يختلف مع المتحدث الاخر
الضيف الاخر
يقوم به فهو فهو الصحيح يتكلم باللهجه
ناعم وخفيفه مقارنه همم وزراهه ولكن هدافه
البعيد المدى هو تحقيق اسرائيل الكبرى ولا
اعتقد ان العالم يقبل بذلك وامل ان
الولايات المتحده
والكونغرس لن يقبل ذلك بالتاكيد لا ينبغي
ان يفعل ذلك لان هذا انتهاك لكل ما نؤمن
به
للسياسه التي طالما اتبعناها في الواقع
منذ اكثر اكثر من 70 سنه اذا
اسرائيل اذا محاوله
اخفاء همم
القيام بهذه الامور فانه نتائج
جمهور الصعيدي حتى لم يقبل ذلك
من يقول بان حتى الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الحاليه ليست في افضل حالاتها هناك انقسام
حاد في همم اسرائيل وبالتالي هذه فرصه
لهذا الوفد الامريكي ومستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي ان يوصل رساله قويه لحكومه 200
ريال
صحيح ولكن هناك جانبين في الموضوع الجانب
الاول ان هذه الحكومه حكومه تجمع ما بين
الفساد والفشيه
وتكرس نظام الابر تايد العنصري الذي انشئ
موجود على الارض يعني ليس سينشا الان هناك
نظام مطر تايد عنصري اشارت له منظمات حقوق
الانسان في العالم بما في ذلك يوم الريس
ووتش وامنيست انترناشونال وحتى بتسلم
الاسرائيليه اذا نحن امام نظام افرتايد
قنصري وفي نفس الوقت نظام فاسد والصراع
الداخلي الاسرائيلي الصراع الداخلي
الاسرائيلي يدور
على قضيه القضاء وعلى قضايا اخرى لانه
نتنياهو يريد ان يغير القضاء حتى يحمي
نفسه من المحاكمه على الفساد ولكن جوهر
الامير للاسف الشديد ان الحكومه السابقه
الاسرائيليه التي حتى لم يكن فيها بين
كبير كانت ايضا تكرر نظام الابر تايد
العنصري القضيه التي يريد ان اقولها
النظام الابر تايد الان ليس تهديدا سيحدث
وانما قائم وبالتالي المدخل بان يكون ليس
فقط من منطلق مصلحه اسرائيل ان لا تكون
نظام افاتايد بل ايضا من زاويه العداله
الدوليه من زاويه حق الشعب الفلسطيني ان
يكون حررا كيف يمكن القبول بان يستعبد شعب
فلسطيني في نظام ابارتايد عنصري واحتلال
هو الاطول في التاريخ البشري وهذا يقودنا
الى السؤال المركزي لماذا ازدواجيه
المعايير لذلك المطلوب مقاطعه هذا النظام
الذي انشا برتايد فورا حتى يعاقب على ما
يقوم به من رام الله دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الى من العام المباد الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
شكرا لك وكذلك
عضو مجلس النواب الامريكي السابق عن الحزب
الديمقراطيته
في هذه الاثناء زار وفد من قناصل وممثلين
عن دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول اخرى المسجد
الاقصى والتقى مسؤولين في دائره الاوقاف
الاسلاميه في القدس المحتله وخلال الزياره
اكد الوفد موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي من اهميه
الحفاظ على الوضع القانوني والتاريخي في
المسجد الاقصى واحترام الوصايه الاردنيه
على المقدسه
اخرى لوفد دبلوماسي من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي للمسجد الاقصى لكن ليس بهذا
التوقيت ولا بما احيط بها من ضغوط مارسها
الجانب الاسرائيلي لتنسيق الزياره معه
وليس مع الاوقاف الاسلاميه
رفض الوفد ذلك باعتباره تغييرا للوضع
القانوني والتاريخي القائم في المسجد وهو
تماما ما اراد ان يتجنبه لم يدلي الوفد
باي تصريحات فزيارته تحدثت بنفسها عن
اهدافها
فيها
رساله الدعم واسناد لدائره الاوقاف
الاسلاميه وايضا دعم لا وصايد جلاله الملك
على المقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه في
مدينه القدس نحن في دائره الاوقاف شرحنا
لهم اوضاعنا في المسجد مع ما نوعيه من
تعطيل من عرقله اعمال للوقاف
سيارته بعد يوم واحد على عرقله شرطه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي دخول السفير الاردني
للمسجد الاقصى بذريعه عدم التنسيق المسبق
وكذلك بعد الاقتحام الاستفزازي لوزير
الامن القومي تمر بن كبير للمسجد بدايت
هذا العام ما يحصل الان هو محاوله ترجمه
فرض السياده الاسرائيليه الكامله على
المسجد الاقصى المبارك الى واقع بعد زياره
من غفير اللي تمت ما بعد اعلان حكومه
نتنياهو وما حصل بالامس من منع السفير
الاردني هي محاوله لتقليص الدور الاردني
على حساب همم الوصايا الاردنيه اللي يجب
ان يحترم بالمسجد الاقصى المبارك
عبرت جهات دوليه عده عن خشيتها من ان يقود
تصعيد الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده الى
انفجار الموقف وبدات تلوح خطوات خجلا
لمواجهه ذلك اذ طلب وفد من مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي عدم الالتقاء باي من وزراء
التيار الصهيوني الديني او اعضاءه كما
يجري مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيكسوليفان مباحثات مع مسؤولين اسرائيليين
ويتوقع ان يطلب خلال لها عدم اتخاذ اي
خطوه قد تفجر الاوضاع لكن في المقابله
يخشى الفلسطينيون ان تحول الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ما يصنف انتهاكات الى جزء مما
يسمى الوضع القانوني القائم
يول الفلسطينيون اهميه بالغه لهذه الزياره
من حيث رسالتها وتوقيتها لكنهم يشددون
ايضا على ضروره تحرك الدول العربيه
والمجتمع الدولي وترجمه المواقف الى افعال
في مواجهه انتهاكات الاحتلال المستمره
للمقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه على حد سواء
نجوى سمري الجزيره القدس المحتله
السلام في الشرق الاوسط عن قلقه البالغ
اذا تاثير الاجراءات الاسرائيليه العقربيه
على الوضع المالي للسلطه الفلسطينيه واكد
ايسلندا خلال جلسه المفتوحه لمجلس الامن
الدولي اهميه محاسبه مرتكبي اعمال العنف
في الضفه الغربيه وتقديمهم الى العداله
دكتور دكتور
على قوه الامن ممارسه اقصى درجات ضبط
النفس وعدم استخدام القوه المميته الا
عندما لا يمكن تجنبها من اجل حمايه
الارواح في السادس من يناير وفق مجلس
الوزراء الامني الاسرائيلي على سلسله من
الاجراءات ضد السلطه الفلسطينيه في الثامن
من يناير اصدر وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
تعليمات لسلطه الضرائب بتنفيذ حجز اموال
الضرائب الفلسطينيه لدفع هذه الاغراض
تاثير مثل هذه الاجراءات في الوضع المالي
للسلطه الفلسطينيه
ومن جهتها عبرت المندوبه الولايات المتحده
في الامم المتحده ليندا عن معارضه بلادها
للاجراءات الاحاديه التي تهدد الاستقرار
وامكانيه تحقيق حل للدولتين
شويه
وامكانيه حدوث مزيد من الاضطراب وندين
الاعمال الارهابيه الاخيره في الضفه
الغربيه نحن منزعجون بشده من عدد الضحايا
الذي يبدو انه في الزياده يجب اتخاذ
التدابير عاجله وملموسه لمنع المزيد من
الخسائر في الارواح اسمحوا لي ان اكون
واضحه نعرض الاجراءات الاحاديه التي تعرض
الاستقرار وامكانيه حل الدولتين للخطر
ان بعبد الله
[موسيقى]
ده رئيس الاوكرانيه بلودفيرسكي الى تسريع
خطوات تزويد بلاده بالدبابات الغربيه قبل
حصول اي هجوم جديد من قبل روسيا واتهم
زنسكي في كلمه له امام المنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي في مدينه دافوس السويسريه اتهمم
موسكو بتهديد العالم بحرب طويله الامل
اغنيه
العالم ويحتاج الى الحزم والسرعه روسيا
تنشر الارهاب وتتحدى العالم وتهدد بحرب
طويله اوكرانيا تعرض معادله لتحقيق السلام
يجب ان تكون خطواتنا اسرع من تحركات روسيا
القادمه يجب ان نتحد ضد عدونا المشترك
تزويد اوكرانيا بمنظمات الدفاع الجوي يجب
ان يكون اسرع من هجمات روسيا الصاروخيه
القادمه تزويدنا بالدبابات الغربيه يجب ان
يكون اسرع من اي هجوم روسي جديد استعاده
الامن والسلامه في اوكرانيا يجب ان تكون
اسرع من هجمات روسيا على امن وسلامي دول
اخرى
ومع استعداد وزراء الدفاع في حلف الناتور
الاجتماعيه يوم الجمعه المقبل في المانيا
تتعرض برلين لضغوط الغربي للقبول بتزويد
كياف بدبابات اليوبارد القتاليه الحديثه
لمواجهه القوه الروسيه وقد نقلت صحيفه
جورنال عن مسؤولين المان قولهم ان برلين
لم تسمح لهلفائها بتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
المانيه الصنع ما لم ترسل واشنطن دباباتها
اوروبا
قتاليه هكذا يقول حلف شمال الاطلسي وهو
يسارع الخطا الاجتماعي
يوم الجمعه المقبل في قاعده رمشتاين
الجويه في المانيا
واصد ذلك ترددت كلمه الدبابات كثيرا فهي
التي بموسوعها وفق كييف ان تحذف فرقا على
الارض وتركيز تصريحا وتلميحا بدل منصبا
على المانيا وتحديدا على الدبابات
اليوبارد 2 ويحتاج الامر الى موافقه برلين
لارسالها وزير الخارجيه الفلندي بكهافيستو
تحدث عن حاجتك للدبابات في لقاء خاص
للجزيره على هامشي منتدياتوس
وهناك مشاورات مع المانيا قلنا ان لدينا
في مخزناتنا دبابات اثنان وطبعا المانيا
وبولندا ستقدمان اعدادا اكبر لكن يمكن ان
نساعد نحن ايضا من خلال الصيانه والتدريب
على الدبابات
تعد دبابات وليوبارد اثنين الالمانيه
الموجوده في نحو 20 دوله من افضل
المجنزرات في الغرب تعتبر من دبابات
القتال الرئيسيه وتبلغ سرعتها القصوى نحو
70 كيلومترا في الساعه تزن الدبابه
الواحده اكثر من 60 طن وهي مزوده بمدفع من
عيار 120 ملمترا ويمكنها اصابه الاهداف
على مسافه تصل الى خمس كيلومترات وتوصف
بانها المزيج المثالي من الحمايه والتنقل
والقدره على المناوره والقوه الناريه
استخدام الدبابات القتال الرئيسيه
الالمانيه الصنع وحدث حلفائها قائله
ارسلوا دباباتكم الى اوكرانيا الان حتى لا
تضطر الى التعامل مع الدبابات الروسيه في
وقت لاحق تزويد اوكرانيا بمنظمات الدفاع
الجوي يجب ان يكون اسرع منها هجمات روسيا
الصاروخيه القادمه تزويدنا بالدبابات
الغربيه يجب ان يكون اسرع من اي هجوم روسي
جديد وقد تكونوا تطورات الاخيره خصوصا في
الجبهه الشرقيه شكلت عامل ضغط رئيس المجلس
الاوروبيات في وجه ما وصفها باستراتيجيه
تدمير وارهاب تنتهي في حربها على اوكرانيا
بولندا اعلنت انها سترسل السريه دبابات من
نوع اليوبارد اثنين الى اوكرانيا وحدث
بريطانيا احد وفرنسا وبولندا بتعاهد
بتقديم المزيد من الاسلحه بين هدبابات
قتاليه بينما قالت اسبانيا ان تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات غير مطروح حاليا حاله
الاستضاف الاوروبيه بمعيه الولايات
المتحده دفعت وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
الاتهام واشنطن بتشكيل تحالف ضد روسيا
يشبه ممارسات الزعيم النازي ادولف هتلر ضد
الاتحاد السوفيتي بينما قال الرئيس الروسي
انه يثق بنصر في الحرب انطلاقا من النتيجه
النهائيه والنصر الحتمي هناك امور القادمه
اسلحه الغربيه والدبابات الالمانيه ضروريه
للبقاء على قيد الحياه
ارحب بضيفيه من وارسو روبرت تشيل المدير
السابق لمكتب معلومات انيته في روسيا
والدبلوماسيه سابق في الخارجيه البولنديه
وكذلك ضيفي من موسكو اليكساندر ارتمانوف
وهو الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي والمختص
في شؤون وابدا بضيفي من
اغوارنا في الاداره الامريكيه ان واشنطن
بدات تقتنع بانه ربما تقدم لكياف اسلحه
تمكنها من الوصول الى شبه جزيره القرم الى
اي مدى هذا وارد
انا
نقاشات في واشنطن كما يحصل في العديد من
العواصم الاوروبيه واعتقد ان من المهم جدا
من هذا النقاش حول مساله التجهيز الاسلحه
المتطوره هناك بعض
الامور المعقده لكن القضيه واضحه هنالك
اعتداء من دوله واحده من روسيا ضد
اوكرانيا روسيا تحت اللوق بشكل غير قانوني
اجزاء من الاراضي الاوكرانيه بعضها من عام
2014 وبعضها همم من السنه الماضيه لذلك
حسب ميثاق الامم المتحده فان اوكراني
لديها حق كامل في الدفاع عن نفسها والدول
الاخرى لديها الحق في ان تدعمها اوكرانيا
اذا لم تكن حتى ولم تكن جزءا من الصراع
العسكريه او الحرب لكن ليس هنالك اي شكل
من هو من هي الجهه المعتديه هي روسيا ماذا
لو فعلا زودت الاداره الامريكيه كيف
باسلحه
تصل الى شبه جزيره القرم
سوف نقوم فوري وسوف نرد بالمراكز
الاستراتيجيه حيث سوف تكون هذه المعدات
واذا كان هناك اي تلميح عن ان هناك معدات
سوف تصل الى القرن يجب ان يتاكد الجميع
اننا لن ننتظر وسوف نقوم بالرد فورا اذا
كان
الحديث عن العمليه العسكريه كما يسميها
السيد همم
اي معدات من هذا النوع قد تحول المعركه
الى المعركه شامله قد تصل الى الضرب في
امريكا نفسها
طيب في هذه الحلقه الان ايضا التركيز من
قبل الجانب الاخراني عن انظمه الدفاع
الجوي وعن الدبابات يطلبها من الحلفائه
الى اي مدى هذه النوعيه من الاسلحه قد
تقلب المعادله فيما يجري في اوكرانيا
اراضي المعركه لكن اذا ما قارننا الموقف
على ما كان عليه
الموقف في فبراير انما بدات روسيا
الاعتداء على اوكرانيا
كانت روسيا تعمل
بسيطره على كيف وانت تسيطر على كل اراضي
اوكرانيا وهذا لم يحصل لكن ما حصل ان
اوكرانيا كانت ناجحه في الدفاع عن نفسها
لكن حقيقه الامر مره اخرى ودعني اكرر هذا
الامر همم
وهي منظمه دعائيه روسيه تدفع لها الحكومه
الروسيه بالتالي لدينا هذه التهديدات من
قبل هي لم تنجح المجتمع الدولي مصمم على
ان قوه وروسيا
لا لا يحققان النجاح في هذه الحرب النصر
في حربهم في اوكرانيا هذه هي الرساله التي
نسمعها في كل يوم هنالك اجتماع للنيتا
وهنالك اجتماع خاص في رمشتاق ايضا حاول
ليه هنالك 50 دوله تشارك وسنسمع المزيد عن
تقديم الدعم
حتى الان هناك تبدو حسابات دقيقه بين
حلفاء كياب مثلا المانيا رغم عليها من
ضغوط وتسلم اوكرانيا
اليوبارد الا انها تقول لن اسلم حتى تسلم
واشنطن دبابات
احدث
نقاشات نعم داخل
او بين الدول الغربيه وبالتاكيد هنالك بعض
الدول في هذه الحاله المانيا قد اتخذت ما
يسميه البعض موقفا حذرا لكن هذه المواقف
تغيرت علينا لا ننسى قبل اشهر
لم يكن هنالك اي حديث عن مساله تجهيز
انظمه بطاريه باتريات لكن تم تجهيزها وتم
تدريب الاوكرانيين على الاستخدامها وايضا
ينطبق الشيء على المعدات العسكريه الاخرى
ذلك الموقف تغير والسبب في ذلك ان العالم
المتحضر لن يقبل
همم هزيمه اوكرانيا لان هذا الامر سيمثل
ممم نموذج فظيعا لبقيه المجتمع الدوليه
بحيث ان ااه
فيما يتعلق بهذه الاجتماعات المكثفه هذه
الوعود بالتقديم السريع لهذه النوعيه من
الاسلحه التي ربما قد فعلا تغير ما يجري
في اوكرانيا وبالتالي ماذا عن الحسابات
الروسيه حيا لكل هذه الوعود وكل هذه
التحرك من قبل الحلفاء
رشيقي
الاوضاع جديده امريكا
[موسيقى]
لا ينصح بها في اراضي اخرى عارك لان هذه
الدبابات ممكن ان تدمر بسهوله ان هكذا
الوقت
للاسفاندر الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
والمختص في شؤون النت وكذلك الشكر لضيفي
منوار صوره برشال المديره السابق لمكتب
معلومات انيته في روسيا والدبلوماسي
السابق في الخارجيه البولنديه
في لقاء خاصه بالجزيره على هامش اكد
الرئيس
اوكرانيا عسكريه
لا استطيع الاجابه كم ستدوم هذه الحرب لان
المساله معقده نرى ان النظام الكريم يستمد
من اجل الاستمرار في الحرب مهما كانت
الكلفه وعلى حساب المجتمع الروسي في ظل
ذلك من الصعب القول ان الحرب ستنتهي خلال
اشهر لكن علينا بذل مزيد من الجهود
لمساعده اوكرانيا لا تساورون اي شكوكا بان
روسيا ستتوقف عند اوكرانيا بل ستكون لها
اهداف اخرى مثل اوروبا
وقالت وزيره الخارجيه سلوفينيا ثانيه
فيرونا قاره اوروبا تواجه كارثه كبرى بسبب
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا واضافت مقابله
مع الجزيره ان بلادها تدعم الاوكرانيين في
حربهم للدفاع عن سيادتهم
الاوروبيه
وهذه الجرائم ضد المدنيين ضد البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه
[موسيقى]
بقي 18 شخصا بينهم وزير الداخليه
الاوكراني ونائبه وزير دوله اضافه الى
طفلين مصر 29 اخرون في تحطم المروحيه في
بروفايل قرب العاصمه
طائره مروحيه تحطمت فوق روضه للاطفال
واصطى ضباب كثيف في منطقه سكنيه
كان على متنها وزير الداخليه الاوكراني
واثنان من كبار المسؤولين قتلوا جميعهم مع
مساعدهم وطاقم الطائره اضافه الى عدد من
القتل والجرح المدنيين بينهم اطفال
الروضه
هنا خوف وهلعلق وقلق على مصير الاطفال ممن
كانوا مع اهاليهم في المكان لحظه وقوع
الكارثه وفيما لم تتضح الملابسات بعد شكلت
السلطات الاوكرانيه لجنه للتحقيق في
الحادث
هناك هناك
لا استطيع اعطاء معلومات
هليكوبتر وعلامتها وزير الداخليه وبعض من
كبار المسؤولين في وزاره بعيدا عن جبهه
القتال غير مسبوقا منذ اندلاع الحرب وحسب
رئاسه الاوكرانيه فان وزير الداخليه
ومرافقه كانوا يتجهون الى احدى النقاط
الحربيه الساخنه ويسجل البحث في ظروف
الحادث الذي وصفه الرئيس
بالماساوي كاترين حنا الجزيره بروفاري شرق
اكياس
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسمي الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الرئيس الامريكي يعتقد انه يجب على
الولايات المتحده بيع تركيا مقاتله اف 16
لتحديث اسطولها الحليب وقد وصف وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
علاقه بلاده بتركيا بانها علاقه شراكه
قويه واضاف خلال استقباله نظيره التركي
مولود شهر اوغلو ان الولايات المتحده
وتركيا تعمل معا في اطار عدد من القضايا
انطلاقا من كونه
بدوره شدد وزير الخارجيه تركي على اهميه
التعاون بلاده مع الولايات المتحده في
محاربه الارهاب وتعزيز التعاون بما يشكل
تهديدا لتنظيم الدوله وحزب العمال
لكردستاني واضاف انقره تنتظر موافقه
واشنطن على صفقه مقاتله اف 16 بما يتماشى
مع مصالح الدولتين الاستراتيجيه
يذهب الينا من الخارجيه الامريكيه مراسل
الجزيره محمد الاحمد محمد ماذا عن هذا
اللقاء وربما العنوان الابرز ما تعلق
بطائره اف 16
هو اللقاء مهم في الواقع عبد القادر في
الوقت الذي تشتهر فيه العلاقات الامريكيه
التركيه جدا في عدد من القضايا سواء
الثنائيه او الاقليميه في مقدمه سوريا
سواء من الناحيتين السياسيه والميدانيه
وايضا عدد من القضايا الدوليه في مقدمتها
اوكرانيا
وروسيا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو
شدد على ان الجانبين على مجموعه واسعه من
القضايا ضمن حلف النيته ثمن دور تركيا في
اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب العام الماضي من
البحر الاسود وايضا جدد على الشراك القويه
بين الجانبين بالرغم من اقراره بوجود
خلافات بالنسبه للجانب التركي وزير
الخارجيه التركي عرج على القضايا التي
سيتم طرحها في جدول اعمال هذا اللقاء اولا
تعزيز التعاون العسكري بين الجانبين بما
في ذلك صفقه الاف 16 التي تقدمت بها تركيا
للحصول على اربعين مقاتله امريكيه من طراز
اف 16
المسؤول التركي الى انقره تتوقع موافقه
الو المتحده على هذه الصفقه ماشيا كما قال
مع المصالح الاستراتيجيه بين الجانب
الجانبين بالرغم من وجود تحفظات بل حتى
معارضه في الكونغرس اقليم مثل هذه الصفقه
سيما من بوب منديس رئيس لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ الذي هدد بوقف
هذه الصفقه ما لم تغير انقره من سياساتها
لكن يتوقع على نطاق واسع ان تمضي الاداره
الامريكيه في هذه الصفقه كما سمعنا قبل
قليل من النت برايس المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الذي اشار الى اندرويد الاخيره في مدريد
اعرض عن دعمه لهذه الصفحه وتحديث الاسطول
همم
من هذه المقاتلات وايضا ضمان امتلاكها
القدرات لمعالجات وتعامل مع مخاوف الامنيه
المشتركه بين البريد البلدين وهذه الخطوه
هذه الصفقه تهدف من خلالها واشنطن عبد
القادر لحاث تركيا على تسريع انضمام
والسويد الى حلف شمال الاطلسي النيته
ويتوقع على اقوى واسع ان موافقه الكونجرس
على هذه الصفقه ستكون مشروطه ومكونه
بموافقه تركيا على انضمام كل من فنلندا
والسويد الى حلف شمال الاطلسي مقر الخارج
وفي هذه الاثناء قال وزير الخارجيه
الفنلندي بيكا هابيستو ان بلاده اوفت بكل
تعاهدات التي قدمتها لتركيا فيما يتعلق
بالانضمام
في مقابله مع الجزيره على هامشي قمه دافوس
ان تساهم زياره وزير الخارجيه التركي الى
الولايات المتحده في حيل في حل اي
اشكاليات عالقه بخصوص هذا الملف
اعتقد اننا نفذنا ما علينا فيما يتعلق
بمكافحه الارهاب
وحلف حزب العمال الكردستاني لكن على مستوى
اللقاءات بين على مستوى الوزراء كانت
اللقاءات ممتازه الان نحن ننتظر القرارات
السياسه نعلم ان في تركيا انتخابات قادمه
والوزير الخارج شغل موجود في واشنطن الان
لبحث التعاون العسكري التركي الامريكي وهو
ايضا قد يكون جزءا من الحل في قضيتنا ايضا
وتبقى مساله توسيع حلف شمال الاطلسي عالقه
بانتظار موافقه تركيا على انضمام السويد
وفنلندا فشرت انقره المسبق يتمحور حول
تنفيذ مذكره تفاهم ثنائيه بينها وبين
ستوكهولم وهلسينكي والتي تنص على تسليم
اشخاص تعتبرهم تركيا ارهابيين وحظر عمل
احزاب وتنظيمات تدرجها على قوائم الارهاب
تقدمت السويد وفنلندا بطلب الانضمام الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي لتتخلي بذلك هل سينك و
ستوكهولم عن الحياه العسكريه التي تلتزمان
به منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
مساءا قد يتحولوا الى تاريخ المفصلي ان
انتهى وفقا ما تريدانه اثارت حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا مخاوفهما وهما من دول الجوار
الروسي
ترى السويد وفنلندا ان عضويتهما في النيتو
ستشكل ضمانه لهما في وجه اي تهديدات روسيه
مستقبلا
ولحلف الناتو سيزيد انضمام الدولتين من
توسعه الجيو سياسي للدفاع عن دول البلطيق
التي يعتبرها الحلف بمثابه خاصرته الضعيفه
وسيصبح للحلف حدود اكثر قربا مع روسيا
ويتحول الى لاعب الرئيسي في الصراع معها
على النفوذ والموارد لكن الطموح قد يكون
ابعد منال على المدى المنثور في امتناع
تركيا يقف عائقا امام انضمام السويد
وفنلندا وتوسعه النيدو التي تحتاج الى
موافقه جميع اعضاء الحلف فانقر لن تقبل
الا بشروط تتعلق بانها القومي كما تقول
على هلسن تسليم من تصنفهم تركيا ارهابيين
كما تطالب وجماعات
على لائحه الارهاب وعلى راسها حزب العمال
الكردستاني
في اللذه من جهتها تقول انها اوفت بما
عليها فيما يتعلق بمطالب تركيا
وتؤكد السويد انها قامت بما يلزم هي
الاخرى وعلى انقر البدء بالتصديق على
عضويتها
وبين البحث عن توسيع دائره النفوذ ومن يرى
الامن القوميه اولويه لا تنازل عنها يبقى
مصير توسع الحلف من عدمه في دائره الترقب
على الاقل
[موسيقى]
عوده الى تسليحه اوكرانيا ومعاناه
الولايات المتحده من نفادي الذخيره
المتطوره التي يمكن نقلها الى كياب فما هو
الحل
مستودعات للمعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
اقامتها واشنطن في اسرائيل قبل عقود
لاستخدامها في حاله الطوارئ
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي في ظل حكومه السابقه
على نقل بعض من هذه الذخيره لكيف تقول انه
بمقتضى الاتفاق نقل الى اوكرانيا نحو
300,000 قذيفه مدفعيه من عيار 155 ملم
وجاء في التقرير الصحيفه ان نحو نصف
القذائف التي تم شحنها الى اوروبا تمهيدا
لتسليمها في النهايه لاوكرانيا عبر بولندا
هذا ويستخدم الجيش الاوكراني حوالي 90000
طلقت مدفعيه شهريا اي ضعف ما تنتجه
الولايات المتحده واوروبا مجتمعه
كانت اسرائيل قد رفض طيله الفتره الحرب
ااا تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه خوفا من تضرر
علاقتها مع روسيا لكن المسؤولين
الامريكيين لاسرائيل العسكريين عفوا
الاسرائيليين وافقوا على خطه نقل الذخائر
الامريكيه لتجنب التوتر مع واشنطن بحسب
نيويورك تايمز وتعود اصول مخزون المعدات
والذخائر العسكريه الامريكيه في اسرائيل
الى حرب اكتوبر عام 73 حينما نقلت
الولايات المتحده جوا اسلحه لامداد القوه
الاسرائيليه
وبعد الحرب تم انشاءه مخازن حرب او
مستودعات ذخيره امريكيه في اسرائيل
لاستخدامها في حال اندلاع ازمه الازمه
مستقبلا ولم يسمح لاسرائيل باستخدام هذا
المخزون الا خلال الحرب على لبنان عام
2006 او الحرب على قطاع غزه عام 2014
ووفقا لتقرير صادر عن الكونجرس في فبراير
شباط الماضي
بطبيعه الحال تقوم الولايات المتحده
باعاده ملا مخزون في مستودعات الذخيره
الامريكيه باسرائيل بصوره دائمه وتنقل
رويترز عن ديفيد ايفري وهو مدير عام سابقي
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه وجنرال سابق في
القوات الجويه قوله انه على الرغم من ان
هذه الامدادات في اسرائيل فان الامريكيين
لا يحتاجون الى ابن ل نقلها فهي ممتلكات
امريكيه
للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع من واشنطن لاري
كورب وهو مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
السابق وكبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم
الامريكي سيد قرب هل اللجوء الى هذا
المخزون الاستراتيجي في اسرائيل معناه ان
واشنطن تعاني عجزا في تزويد اوكرانيا مع
تطور الحرب بهذه الذخائر
لهذه الذخيره في اوكرانيا ضد القوات
الروسيه بالتاكيد لان الحرب استمر بما
توقعناها فان الولايات المتحده قد استنفذت
امداداتها وتريد ان تبقي هذه الامدادات
مستمره ايضا هذا الحال مع الحلفاء
بالتاريخ مثلا في اسرائيل وهي كوريا
الجنوبيه ايضا لدينا مخازن للاسلحه لاننا
قلقون ايضا مثلا من هجومي كوريا الشماليه
بالتالي تقوم بارسال هذه
الاخيره الى اوكرانيا لكي تستمر في يمكن
ان نراه ربما هجوم ربيعي واذا ما تمتنا
واذا ما حصل ذلك
طويله وبالتالي ماذا عن الحسابات
الامريكيه ما يتعلق بالذقائر ان طالت
الحرب
وكما
اليوم ان هذه الاخيره لدينا مخزن اخرى كما
قلت في كوريا الجنوبيه من اجل تعويض ما
يتم استخدامه لكننا لا نريد ان نستنفذ
مخزوننا ربما اذا ما كان هنالك حاله حرب
مثلا ضد الصين او اي بلد اخر نقوم باستبدا
التي همم قام الكثير من حلفائنا بتوزيد
بتزويدها اوكرانيا ومن هذا امر مدير لحد
الان اسرائيل تحاول ان تبقى خارجه هذه
الحرب لا تبدو وكانها هي معاديه لروسيا
هل اسرائيل بشكل او باخر
تدخل في الحسابات باستعمال هذا المخزون
الذي هو على اراضيها
ان اسرائيل لا يمكنها ان تقام عندما تكون
تطلب الولايات المتحده ان تقوم به لانها
مجهز اساسي للاسلحه لاسرائيل وحسب الاتفاق
في عام 1973 بين اسرائيل ومصر بشكل اساسي
هذا يعني ايضا انه
اردنا انها هذه الحرب باسرع وقت ممكن كما
ذكرت سابقا هذا الامر يضع اسرائيل في موقف
صعب لاننا نريد ان تبقى الموقف الحياله
لكن عندما نظرنا الى حقيقه ان ايران وهي
التي تراها اسرائيل
روسيا لربما همم لم تقاوم اسرائيل طلب
الولايات المتحده الاخيره
ماذا لو كان الوضع يختلف اي كان الاتفاق
او ما تم الان مع الحكومه الحاليه الحكومه
هل كان سيتم بنفس الطريقه
اذا ما اخذنا بالنظر الاعتبار التوتر بين
نتنياهو والولايات المتحده لكن كلا اعتقد
ان الامر يظهر يظهر بشكل اساسي ان
الاسرائيلينا يعرفون حتى لو اختلفوا حول
كيفيه استخدامه هذه الذخيره باخذ بنظره
الاعتبار انهم يعتمدون بشكل كبير على
الولايات المتحده بسبب الاتفاق الذي
ابرمناه في عام 1973 ونستمر
وما يحتاجونه للدفاع انفسهم ليس امامهم
خيال سواء ان يتماشوا مع طلب الولايات
المتحده لكن النقطه المهمه اننا لا نرى
اسرائيل
في مركز التقدم الامريكي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
ودع العالم السنه الفرنسيه
لنكون على ما نحن عليه الله الله في كبار
السن الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]